able to be in that type of relationship
because it is so extreme to the point
where sometimes there is a chance of
death yeah because people engage in such
extreme activities you need extreme
trust in order to get into it is there
is there any data that backs this up so
the the idea no this just sounds like
this sounds crazy to me so I I know I'm
I'm going to give you the example okay
because things are so extreme you're not
just going to do it even though it's a
fantasy you're not going to do it unless
you trust that person it's not going to
actually kill you does that make sense
so you have to discuss all the details
you you say what do I like what I don't
like they talk about what are the things
that you might consider what are the
things what is a hard no what is a soft
no what is and after you've done all of
that and you agree that you're going to
give it a try
you have to have a safe word
so what happens in that relationship one
person's the Dom one person's a sub